welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of moon
night episode 2 in which moon knight
narrowly escapes a bunch of vegans by
killing their dog this episode was
filled with easter eggs subtle cinematic
details and even deeper layers of
mystery so let's break down this shot by
shot for everything that you might have
overlooked and a reminder that the best
way you can support us is to get our new
limited edition moon knight inspired
shirt we're selling these off faster
than we thought it's called tomb of the
moon god it looks awesome and when you
get it you'll unlock the added option to
write in a custom shout out for our
after shows so get that at
newrockstarsmerge.com okay opening shot
over sand we hear the sounds of moon
knight's beatdown on that jackal that
ended last episode
here it echoes like a nightmare but we
are awake as we hear this because we're
staring at the sand around his bed and
the fact that that sand is intact means
that someone returned home after that
fight and reset the sand that someone
being mark if it's now stephen awaking
from it thinking it was a dream so mark
is complicit in keeping stephen in this
solution that he's just sleepwalking
last episode i pointed out how steven's
inaugural step in that sand compared
with harrow's first step on glass makes
steven more connected to the sands of
egypt and this episode ends with mark
back in the desert from sand we begin
and to sand we shall return but steven
ain't ready to take those steps he
springs out of bed slips on the sand
stumbles landing on his face just like
he landed in the alps after mark had
been in control it seems like steven is
going to repeatedly land on his face
just like this also his foot harness
tightens so that now it's like he is
being leashed to the bed what was meant
to be a harness for his sleepwalking
alter ego is really confining himself
now among the stack of books in front of
him is one titled adventures of the soul
journeys through the physical and the
spiritual dimensions this is a real 2014
book by a medium named james van praag
about the human soul and how it fits
into this life and how it travels in the
spiritual realm so really stephen isn't
totally unfamiliar with a soul's
detachment from the physical body also i
didn't mention this last episode but
among steven's textbooks are a book
about asgard what's old is new again and
another one about wakanda which we
should note worships the panther deity
bost which is derived from the egyptian
feline deity of bastet stephen opens his
cabinet mirror to confront mark
yeah think so now it might just be the
way the camera or the cabinet moves but
it does look like his reflection of his
reflection on the far right does turn
his head a little independently of how
steven turns his head then stephen steps
up to london's national gallery while
production was in budapest and last week
the museum was a budapest museum this is
actually london's trafalgar square
that's nelson's column to the left with
the lions the double-decker bus that
passes is an ad for made chandeliers the
verona light another shakespeare
reference to romeo and juliet
verona where in the most famous scene
romeo compares juliet to the sun his
verona light and begs her to kill the
envious moon in this episode this romeo
reunites with his juliet and hopes to
end his toxic moon entity as he enters
the museum the camera tilts following
him until we are upside down reminding
us my favorite shot last episode when we
thought we were right side up looking at
a puddle until a leaf proved that we
were actually upside down all of it
showing how steven's self-perception is
actually illusory in jb's security arena
several cameras are pointed at the
sarcophagus that steven showed the girl
last episode and beside that there is a
qr code on the wall that actually links
to a digital copy of werewolf finite
number 32 which was the first comic
appearance of the moon knight character
that same qr code actually shows up this
episode on the number 43 locker at the
storage facility except now marvel
updated the link so that it takes you to
werewolf by night number 33 so i'm
guessing we're gonna see these qr codes
in many episodes throughout the season
and they'll just update it with new
issues each week and uh i think i just
put together that steven's fish's name
of gus might be short for sarcophagus
they watch back the security footage but
there is no jackal it's just steven
reacting to nothing now fight club has
been mentioned as an influence and this
seems like a nod to the scene of fight
club where edward norton's character
fights tyler durden but later on
security footage shows him hitting
himself but if you look closely at this
footage as steven runs past that column
there's some digital noise on the screen
and if you compare this last episode
that was right when the jackal hit that
surface so while the jackal is invisible
to everyone else something caused that
static stephen says there was a dog
chasing me like a big like a handle oh
yeah anna the baskervilles was it yes
referencing the hound of the
baskervilles the third of the four
sherlock holmes novels written by sir
arthur conan doyle a mystery about a
phantom dog plaguing an estate it was
actually really an inheritance scheme
similar to the hound that chases steve
in this episode if you think about it
really boils down to inheritance scheme
arthur harrow having issues with konshu
for choosing mark spector as an avatar
and mark spector not wanting the
beneficiary of these abilities to pass
on to his wife and the footage ends with
mark confidently stepping out and
staring directly at the camera as if
knowing steven the next day would review
this footage that's not me
the desk in the hr office again gives us
a clean reflection of steven the hr
manager offers therapy this particular
group of doctors has a long-standing
relationship with us but the fact that
he doesn't get the police involved but
then some cops who do get involved these
detectives end up being part of harrow's
cult makes me wonder if this hr rep is
also part of that cult as well because
he says you're not alone
yes it's like part of the problem in it
yes you're not alone is a special threat
to stephen we're always watching for the
greater
good if you look at this brochure it
shows a woman holding hands with the
doctor which could be a nod to hero's
emmett assessment which does evoke the
scientology auditing process mt also
pointed out on inside marvel that the
pamphlet is also covered with a logo of
a green crescent moon shape which just
could be a sign that even kanju and his
possession could all be part of steven's
mental health delusions steven is forced
to give up his name badge a name that
even jb never committed to memory
foreshadowing how this episode ends with
steven surrendering his steven identity
to his mark specter identity his
gold-painted friend crawley again his
homeless friend from the comics never
moves a muscle until stephen hugs him
and crowley side eyes him just a little
example of something tricky happening
just outside of steven's perception now
in addition to the qr code detail the
locker number 43 could be a nod to moon
knight number 43 in which moon knight
faces seth falcon a villain who drains a
person's life similar to the way arthur
harrow does in the series the walls of
mark's storage unit are reflective but
noticeably cloudier than the other
reflective surfaces we've seen on the
show maybe a safeguard put in place by
mark so that when he was in this room he
wouldn't accidentally see steven's eyes
and accidentally surrender control back
to him steven finds mark's pistol in
stacks of foreign currency the red 100
notes are chinese yuan making me wonder
what reason mark might have needed to go
to china or interact with chinese buyers
maybe a deal with the 10 rings mark's
american passport lists his birthday as
march 9 1987. oscar isaac's real life
birthday is march 9th for the year 1979
because hollywood subtracts 8 years for
men but then adds 16 for women the issue
date is december 14th 2018 which means
that mark got his passport during the
blip which started in may 2018 of the
mcu timeline confirming that mark was
not dusted during those five years
stephen finds the golden scarab which
hovers over his palm i'd say your
compass
be no point in your nose yeah this
compass would presumably point toward
egypt which is southeast of the uk worth
noting that this would also be the
general compass heading for mecca which
muslims around the world pray in the
direction of throughout the day in this
case the scarab also points directly at
mark's reflection stephen snaps at him
no i don't care how bloody handsome you
are tell me what it is you are yeah
gotta love the meta joke for oscar isaac
there but for steven he sees
handsomeness as a factor of confidence
something he doesn't have thus he's
unable to see his own good looks mark
explains i surf can't you
i'm his avatar
which means you are too
sort of
we
protect the vulnerable
and deliver conscious
justice to those who hurt them mark
pauses before using the word justice as
if intentionally drawing a comparison
between conscious justice after damage
was done between that and on its
judgment before any sins were committed
a distinction that stephen later levies
against harrow steven looks at the gun
now give me the body let me finish this
and you'll never hear from me again
yikes mark is in the reflective surface
of the pistol too it's very dark to
imagine someone hearing these kinds of
voices when pondering picking up a gun
like steven could be imagining one way
to silence mark forever now earlier when
they walked up to this locker the motion
sensor lights of her head slammed on
just setting up this awesome scare with
konchu now flashing in and out of the
lights with louder and louder slams
so the lights alone represent the demon
like the barrels and jaws representing
the shark this also works like an
inverse of david f sandberg's amazing
lights out short the ghost and the light
instead of the ghost in the dark stephen
gazes up at konshu's form as the lamp
overhead glows brighter and brighter and
i just love how you can now see a big
divot in the ridge of his beam like he's
been in some kind of battle in this
ghostly form and then you can see up
into his skull orifices a ribbed texture
interior for our pleasure because the
inside of a lot of skulls are rarely
smooth or sanded down just little
details like this make him more lifelike
layla pulls up to him greeting him
upside down just like that shot of him
entering the museum earlier she says to
him you really could have given me any
sign that you were alive
yeah throughout this conversation he
sees her through the mirror the people
he speaks to in mirror reflections are
just difficult for him to trust is
legitimate in his flat when leila looks
at gus in the tank mark's reflection
appears in the tank behind hers despite
steven being back at the door showing
how mark is now in a kind of sunken
place trapped in an egyptian themed tank
like gus is way out of your depth
brother you're literally in the depths
now on the shelf for some invisible
titles joseph pearl's revealer of
secrets which is considered the first
modern hebrew novel written in 1819 a
satirical collection of letters among
hasidic rabbis mark spector is jewish
son of a rabbi something this series
will explore with the jewish cultural
consultant listed in the credits also
the man in the ice which is a book about
the 1991 discovery of a 5 000 year old
neolithic corpse in the glacier in the
alps is actually not that far from the
valley where stephen woke up last
episode and of course man in the ice we
definitely had another one of those in
the mcu but the book layla picks up is a
collection from french poet marceline
debora de vamore le fleur or the flowers
from the year 1833 the two of them quote
the opening verses from les separae or
the separated marceline debord valmer
centroid
which translates to do not write i am
sad i would like to die out the
beautiful summers without you are the
night without a torch these words
reflect the separation between these two
lovers mark ghosted her wanting to die
out in layla's mind essentially telling
her don't contact me but really without
each other they have been lost in the
darkness earlier in this episode we got
the allusion to this romeo's son making
the moon envious and here's another
literary illusion comparing this
star-crossed lover to a flame in the
night and it's sweet that layla's
favorite poet was stephen's favorite
poet despite him having no other memory
of her and mark even trying to block her
out like mj still wearing peter parker's
broken necklace another example in the
mcu of love persevering through memory
now harder than wrapping your head
around all these details can be wrapping
our head around the environmental impact
of the electronics we use every day a
new smartphone represents about 175
pounds of carbon emissions and 18 000
gallons of water usage so when that
phone or that tablet or the laptop gets
thrown away it also becomes e-waste a
great way to keep toxic e-waste out of
landfills is by purchasing renewed
electronics and our friends at back
market have built an amazing marketplace
that offers expertly renewed smartphones
laptops and other tech for a fraction of
the normal cost i've been using this
amazing 2020 rose gold ipad air from
back market i love it it looks brand new
it costs way less than buying new and it
didn't turn into e-waste that is a sweet
tablet every purchase comes with a
one-year warranty 30 days to change your
mind and free standard shipping plus
with backmarket's new buyback program
you can also sell your old tack for cash
use code rockstar and save 20 on your
first purchase of expertly renewed tech
before april 21st so break up with new
tech and find your next device at
backmarket.com that's back market not
black market when layla finds a scarab
and confirms it does point to amit's
tomb on the table besides stephen a
little gator or a croc statue vomit
ready to devour him then the detectives
knock at the door
dc fitzgerald and dc kennedy here it's
gerald and kennedy interesting names for
detectives because it's the middle name
in the surname of the u.s president john
fitzgerald kennedy because these are
probably fake names recognizable to an
american but less so to a brit actor
anne akagerian is credited as bobby and
david gainley as billy when they bring
in steven run mark's records his file
number begins with 1975. that was the
year moon knight first appeared in
marvel comics and the assigned agent is
nick pepin the real life production
manager on moon knight and several other
marvel titles love it when they work the
crew names in there the photo here shows
at least four bodies shot in the heads
at an archaeological dig site in egypt
which seems like this is all being taken
from moon knight comics where raul
bushman murders marlene's archaeologist
father before mark becomes moon knight
something that may be the case with
layla and her father oh the cops are
drinking the ahmed kool-aid based on
their tattoos there's a tattoo also on
the kid with a soccer ball and her
tattoo seems to even move a bit as she's
holding that ball the soccer ball is
unworthy oh soccer ball it's a shame you
can't be here to see the world we create
arrow greets him i hear you loud and
clear steven grant of the gift shop
oh god
i'm sorry for the wait
yeah they mixed in sounds of broken
glass and sandals on each of his steps
konshu begs stephen to kill harrow break
his windpipe but steven ignores him and
kancho kicks the trash bin just a little
thanks setting up all the invisible
forces smashing stuff in the climax of
this episode hero takes even on a tour
of this cult commune and chats with
jamila in mandarin
yeah again if you listen to his kick
there's a bit of broken glass mixed in
there as konchu watches from the roof
his crescent moon staff frames the
street light above there's no light of
the moon yet showing how kanchu is still
powerless at this point in scene inside
bob dylan's every grain of sand plays
once more just like it did in the
opening scene of the series there's some
cult members watching serene nature
footage just classic clockwork orange
style indoctrination there hero
recommends a lentil soup victor's recipe
gracias victor
he's from the yucatan
miss that is very funny hmm victor there
is a victor mancha in the marvel comics
aka victorious cyborg son of mexican
mother marionella mancha and ultron tech
who's part of the runaways ties in with
the age of ultron storyline later kills
vision son then i don't know if this is
the same victor i just love how harrow
feeds stephen these lentils that were
grown in their community garden while
using a gardening metaphor to describe
ahmet's judgment she tears evil up from
the root casting her judgment before any
evil's done that's why we must resurrect
her almost as if he's saying you're
enjoying our garden trust the gardener
but stephen rightfully counters if army
judges people pre-evil like before the
fact then
isn't she judging an innocent person a
thought can't be evil can it i think
about killing my boss
all the time but i wouldn't actually do
it what about a child would she kill a
child for something they might do in 30
years and stephen doesn't buy harrow
comparing kids to diseased limbs need an
amputation so harrow has to whip out the
big guns this is amit's gift to her
first avatar it contains in a tiny
sliver of her power yes another
reference to amit's first avatar who
betrayed her who might have speculated
could be pharaoh rahmatut aka kkk i know
it sounds like i'm reaching just watch
my video on that i swear i make a pretty
good case for it i like how throughout
this as the cult members back away in
fear that projected nature footage now
shows a hummingbird flapping its wings
and then mushrooms sprouting mirroring
the tension of the scene the chaotic
heartbeat of a hummingbird then
exploding into a mushroom cloud plume
layla arrives to the scarab and they
flee as harrow uses a cane to open a
purple crack in the ground through which
another jackal arises another example of
glowing purple rifts through dimensions
in the mcu after spider-man no way home
perhaps the purple glow indicates the
realm between universes what wong called
the dark border between known and
unknown realities and it is from this
realm where these hell beasts are
summoned hero chants
and honest staff those crocodile eyes of
amit glow purple the jackal knocks
stephen out the window this is likely
the moment he loses a scarab considering
his jacket billows up come on
but steven hits a superhero landing
dressed as a dapper mr knight look taken
directly from war and else's 2014 comics
or as mr knight in the comics is really
a clever criminologist detective another
main form of konchu in this series it's
really just the form stephen grant takes
when he tries to summon konchu the suit
is a finely tailored three-piece suit
with a form-fitting mask with stitching
down the center of the face reflecting
steven's fractured identity but i love
his shoes loafers with these white
wrappings just a little hint of that
mummy linen aesthetic he and mark argue
she said i needed a suit yeah the
ceremonial armor from conscious temple
not psycho colonel sanders i don't know
how only this [ __ ] works yeah i just
like how in response to that the mark
reflection blinks his glowing eyes
slowly and disappointment layla breaks
the bottle over the jackal's head so
that she could see it with the fluid
that's sticking to him but then the
jackal lifts them both and slams him
against the wall as it does so you can
still see the last of those little
droplets of fluid shaking off from the
motion steven tries to lure it away
butterfly's thinking like a bee he's
quoting muhammad ali not realizing that
the second half of that line was his
hands can't hit what his eyes don't see
ironic since he is trying to fight
something invisible to everyone else
also worth noting that mark in the
comics had a past as a boxer steven
instead says
which is a fun nod to the fact that the
mcu already has another stephen with a
ph stephen strange and then after he
hits the jackal he screams
which is slaying used in london that
came from immigrants from caribbean
countries basically meaning what's up or
what's going on the double decker bus
has an ad for the grc reuniting you with
your better half the grc of course is a
global repatriation council the agency
introducing the falcon the winter
soldier that resettles people after the
blip also ironically in this moment
steven is struggling to reconnect with
his other half overhead this bus is
coated with wbn 0032 another nod to
werewolf by knight number 32 moon
knight's first comic appearance also
apparently the one comics references
series is allowed to have easter eggs
for steven has to surrender control and
moon knight ceremonial suit takes over
and i love it beneath those mummy
wrappings gold armor slides out over his
shoulders this automated assembly the
stitching together of the suit is just
so piecemeal and tactile you can see
each thread snaking and binding him just
reminds me of the pieces of iron man's
armor clinking together in that original
2008 film mark unsheathes his chest
weapons which she seems to have an
unlimited supply like cards from a
blackjack slot mark lures the jackal up
the building past the crescent moon
which now glimmers in the background as
we saw last episode the crescent moon
shines when moon knight has the upper
hand as he leaps from rooftop to rooftop
in this thrilling montage that crescent
moon actually gets larger and larger in
the frame symbolizing his growing power
he runs down the timbers reflected in
the surface of the water and it ends as
he impales the jackal on this outdoor
altar and retracts his chest piece in
the light of the crescent moon the two
shapes match in each other this gorgeous
shot composition here and showing how
all of this power is coming from the
moon little detail i spotted here in
that courtyard there is a silhouette of
someone watching in the shadows in the
background might be an onlooker might be
a crew person who got left in frame
might be kanchu steven tries to reclaim
the body you've always managed to keep a
wall between us but something's changed
the one who controls the bodies becomes
stronger the reflections help but most
of the time it'll take all your
willpower just to be a fly on the wall
yes so it sounds like to answer harrow's
query from before mark might have
already had dissociative identity
disorder now conscious possession is
making whichever identity is in control
at any moment stronger at keeping the
other identities suppressed mark says we
wouldn't be alive if it weren't for
conscience in my servitude
is the price that i pay so yes it sounds
like they are adapting mark spectre's
origin from the comics that mark was
dying when he came across conscious tomb
and that's when he got possessed but
stephen now bolder and angrier as one of
the suppressed voices really gets under
mark's skin shut up it gives you a
moment
yes the church bell tolls for mark's
mental break like the bell of a boxing
ring signaling the end of a round
another nod to mark's boxing history
like the church is saying hey break it
up break it up back to your quota now
odd detail here if you count the bell
chimes to try to figure out the hour it
rings at least 14 maybe 15 times which
is crazy because church bell towers
never ring more than 12 so they may have
doubled up because as we cut in and out
of steven's reflection they could have
done that to show both identities
hearing the first couple chimes i love
how conscious appears among the
gargoyles of the roof just blending in
with the surroundings and the shot does
not break from mark's perspective as we
then look up to another rooftop where
conscious suddenly appearing there
mid-sentence and then the camera drifts
right back down to mark where konchu is
right behind him and i love how in the
moonlight now streaming through the tree
you can clearly see how this skull is
actually floating over his body but
those errant hairs connected to his
skull drape downward to make it seem
like there is a connection like a
marionette head defying gravity love
this transition here as conscious steps
across frame his wrappings dissolving
into the falling curtain that mark had
draped over a broken mirror to hide his
reflection since mark is in a different
spot of the room the reflection is
steven covered in a bed sheet on the bed
his knuckles bloody this means that
steven must have tried to break out of
the state violently and injured himself
now looking a lot like martin sheen
after he cut his hands on the broken
mirror in apocalypse now and in that
cracked mirror you can see steven is
wearing the star of david necklace
another nod to his jewish heritage mark
stumbles across the room opening the
curtains to reveal the pyramids of giza
of egypt and i just love that this whole
sudden transition to egypt took us here
while we were in mark's perspective
confirming that konchu backseats his
avatar whoever is at the wheel steven
ormark and that this avatar like us is
really just along for the ride now over
the credits plays the egyptian anthem el
maluke by ahmed saad featuring inaba and
double zuch awesome egyptian jammer to
end this episode and the final shot of
the credits actually changes from last
episode before it was an amazing shot of
moon knight's footed ceremonial warrior
attire now it is mr knight again the
best way to support us is to check out
our great merch options at new
rockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos following
rockstar subscribe to rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you